welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and this video
there's gonna be carnage and did
terrible two terrible jokes there's been
a whole host of new updates surrounding
the upcoming venom sequel and this video
we're gonna be breaking them down and
giving our thoughts on them there will
be heavy spoilers here so we don't
anything potentially ruined about the
movie then I highly recommend that you
turn off now make sure you subscribe to
the channel to keep up to date with the
film and please drop a thumbs up if you
enjoy the video without the way thank
you for clicking this now let's get into
our breakdown of venom
let there be carnage okay so venom 2 was
initially scheduled to release October
the second this year but the film has
now been pushed back to June 25th 2021
the upcoming Matt Reeves Batman movie
was originally supposed to release on
that date however due to delays in
filming it's been pushed back to October
2021 and Sony have now swept in and
taken this spot we'll discuss why this
may be in more detail as we get into the
plot leaks but it was of course
disappointing for fans who were actually
expecting a trailer this month initially
there was hope that the film was not
going to be delayed as Morbius was
rolled back at the end of March and
Benham 2 didn't go with it the add fuel
to the fire a ton of fake information
started hitting the web about the
release of the trailer including an
image that was apparently posted by Andy
Serkis this was then apparently deleted
but it picked up a lot of coverage last
week because most news outlets are
ignoring their spider sense right now
and know it seemed faker than Woody
Harrelson's wig it did end up making the
rounds I think this kind of forced Sony
to step in and make an announcement as
all of their videos were getting
bombarded with released the venom
trailer comments and they announced the
film's full title all whilst pushing it
back so we now know that the movie will
be officially called venom
let there be carnage the this kind of
killed me deep down a bit because on
Twitter for about the last two months
I've been joking that the movie would be
called venom there's going to be carnage
and I just I just god honestly I really
don't like the tie
and I wish they'd gone with just calling
it maximum carnage it has a lot more
weight to it ties back to so many
properties and it's not like studios
don't name things after big releases
such as Days of Future past and age of
Ultron and micro and me but at the
moment I feel like Tom Hardy with venom
at the start of the movie because
because you didn't like it but but it
grew on them anyway this of course means
that the trailer will be pushed back and
though the film officially wrapped on
the 13th of Feb
it is too early to start promoting it
now I know that this is a point that
will get disputed in the comments below
but a survey was compiled a couple of
years ago that looked at trailer release
states from the year 2000 all the way to
2016 they found that the majority of
films didn't drop their first trailer
until a studio was six months within the
release window and only four to five
percent of movies released their first
trailer over a year before the film's
release the air mark was actually even
lower than that so yeah it doesn't seem
likely that we'll be seeing any time
soon going off all of this information
we will probably get the first trailer
in January 2021 so don't hold your
breath now onto the plot leaks we kind
of have to discuss the Morbius leaks in
order to add context to this so if you
don't want that ruined then you better
hope you're in the dead side of Dallas's
snap right now and get dusted out of
here anyway if you're still here thanks
for sticking around and it's rumored
that in the film Morbius will go to jail
and it's here that he will come face to
face with the vulture and scorpion
Morbius causes a prison riot in order to
escape and during this at vulture
Scorpion and cletus kasady all make it
out it's at this point that vulture
tells Morbius he's forming a team and
asks if he wants to get involved I did
believe these leaks to be real and then
when Morbius got pushed back and the
venom sequel didn't I started
questioning it as it ruined the
chronology of the events however with
venom 2 now being pushed back it does in
my mind realign the leaks and it seems
more likely that this will happen
allowing Cletus to escape as for venom
two these are leaks that we've managed
to collate from a number of sources
including reddit 4chan and HN
entertainment they said that the film
showcase
some of Carnage's time in prison in
which he was alongside frances louise
Barisan AKA shriek shriek has been
confirmed for the film and she's been
played by Naomi Harris
Cletus doesn't have the symbiote at the
start of the movie and it's thought to
be set before the events of Morbius we
watch as he built a relationship with
shriek and then get a flash-forward to
the prison escape in Morbius which
leaves them out in the big bad world
according to the leaks the villains
violent past as a child is going to be
heavily explored in the film and we'll
see this through the eyes of the
investigation carried out by Eddie Brock
Tom Hardy did initially post the remains
of an orphanage on Twitter
another photo has now been removed we
can confirm its legitimacy through sites
like comicbook.com reporting on its
existence so we do now know that
cletus's origin story will be discovered
for those that don't know in the comics
Cassidy was a deeply disturbed
individual and a complete homicidal
maniac that took pleasure in causing
death as a child Cassidy's similar to
most serial killers tortured several
animals before moving on to people it's
suspected that his mental conditions
were caused by his father who brutally
beat his mother in front of him whatever
the case Cletus had a very messed-up
childhood that led him further down a
dog path he killed his grandmother by
pushing her down a flight of steps and
he also tried to kill his mother by
electrocuting hair this was done by
throwing a hair dryer into her bath and
naturally she didn't take it too well
she tried to kill Cassidy herself but he
managed to survive and then she was
apparently killed by cletus's father
though it may have been the boy either
way he was sent to st. Esther's home for
boys which was an orphanage here he was
mocked by staff and children because of
his antisocial behavior he pushed a girl
who rejected him in front of a bus and
in the end burned down the orphanage
Brock will apparently unearth all of
this when looking into Cassidy and after
some investigation he'll uncovered that
12 deaths were caused by the villain
these were unknown and they add more to
the characters hefty body count it is
thought that when Brock interviewed
Cletus in the prior movie that he
received a little hint that would lead
him to the orphanage and after exposing
these victims Cassidy will try and hunt
him down in order to stop the new
getting out during this Cassidy gets
infected with carnage which is of course
a spawn of venom we also learn that
right isn't dead and together they help
in fact shriek Cassidy's insanity begins
to infect carnage and it slowly becomes
just as twisted as he is right alerts
the other symbiotes on his home planet
that there are people on earth to feed
upon and they arrive on earth but due to
carnage now being corrupted it becomes
cannibalistic and it begins to feed upon
them this is similar to how right absorb
venom in the first film that's
apparently what we will see when the
symbiotes reached the planet carnage
will absorb them all and become stronger
because of it and we will get the giant
carnage from the comics carnage doesn't
absorb riah shriek and instead he plays
it cool and pretends to be their ally so
that they'll help the fight venom he
does become their leader and they all
team up against the protagonists this is
where venom supposedly reaches out to
spider-man and they to form a team in
order to defeat the symbiotes this is a
part of the plot leaks that I'm a bit
unsure upon as we know Marvel our
precious overthere universe and
currently the connections to the MCU
only seem to be going one way however to
add some weight to it Tom Hardy did post
a photo to his Instagram yesterday of
venom eating spider-man but this was
quickly deleted luckily we managed to
get a video of this so it's not like the
made a bounty circus thing and it was
indeed online I actually managed to see
myself in between liking photos of Tom
Hardy topless anyway after the battle
venom is about to kill Cassidy but
spider-man stops him and venom then
turns on the hero this starts their
cinematic feud and the film is meant to
end by setting up a venom burst
spider-man film and that's all of the
leaks that we could find that seemed to
be like they had at least some
credibility to them take them with a
pinch of salt as you never really know
with leaks if they're real or not but as
the film was close to completion rather
than at the planning stages it does add
more weight the plot kind of sounds a
bit all over the place at some point but
with comic book movies you never know
how the execution will be actually
really like the first venom movie and we
have seen in the past with things like
endgame that the leaks seem like they're
a mess
and then they come together for a great
film the big gutted that got delayed and
so far there's pretty much no comic book
movies outside of Black Widow and Wonder
Woman 84 to look forward to for the rest
of the year
oh well 2021 is gonna be crazy I just
hope we live that long and all the films
don't get overshadowed due to how many
there's going to be anyway one of these
leaks are true and are we do know one
thing and that is there's gonna be
carnage then yeah ruined another video
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the title the leaks and if
you're still excited for the film
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video you know what I do yeah
just just hit the little thumbs up
button and make sure you check out a
breakdown of some of the insane details
and spider-man far from home that we
noticed it's definitely worth checking
out if you love Marvel and if you want
to support the channel from as little as
99 cents a month then please click the
join button below
we appreciate it massively and you get
access to content early if you want to
come chat to us after the show in the
follow us at Definition whitey or click
the discord link in the description
below every month we give away free
movies to people our subscribe to the
channel and this month II can win the
Marvel phase three part one box set and
all you have to do is comment on a video
and make sure you soap with
notifications on the more videos you
comment on the more you have a chance of
winning so make sure you get involved
the winners gonna be chosen at random on
the 15th of May and the set will be
shipped out from then to ever get
surprise so best of luck that everyone
who takes part
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thank you for taking the time to watch
this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]